i was checking into a hotel  and somebody came out and said oh do you  need help with your bags and i've i  thought they were doing a bit  so um i went oh i've been traveling all  day no idea  um kept talking like that  so i had to like slowly transition out  of it and i know that that sounds like  an exaggeration of their voice but then  i was back in the country several years  later and they were on tv on gogglebox  because it was steph and dom from  gogglebox  they so they actually talk like that i  never knew that that was a real hotel  been referencing yeah you stayed there  stayed there yes and accidentally made  fun of them to their face